after much controversy and expectations
former Labor Secretary Tom Perez was
elected chair of the Democratic National
Committee on Saturday replacing the
disgraced interim chair donna Brazile
who herself replaced the disgraced
five-year chair debbie Wasserman Schultz
contentious race the strongest
challenger with congressman keith
Ellison keith Ellison ultimately
defeated by Tom Perez 235 to 200 many
Bernie supporters horrified this exposed
some divisions the idea was that the
Bernie side of the party supported keith
Ellison the establishment side or as i
like to call it the democrats
incorporated sides the business side of
the democrats were with Tom Perez is
that completely accurate not really but
it at least gives us a frame to start
thinking about it but I need to warn you
here I have concerns about this decision
for Democrats but the Trump
administration's move now is going to be
to create more infighting between the
progressive wing and the establishment
wing of the Democratic Party don't fall
for this Trump actually tweeted after
the election results the race for DNC
chairman was of course totally rigged
Bernie's guy like Bernie himself never
had a chance Clinton demanded Paris so
we can be critical of the decision by
the DNC without jumping to what Trump is
doing which is only going to further her
Democrats the truth is that
ideologically Tom Paris and keith
Ellison are almost identical we know
that they're close friends my friend no
Mickey cons recently saw them having
dinner together at a DC restaurant the
political differences are not what's
important what's different is this is
about whether Democrats continue the
direction of Democrats incorporated
meaning raise money recruit candidates
represent Democrats in the media
continue the big political consulting
contract or do we go in the direction of
a more Bernie Sanders message which may
have may have actually defeated drum so
I think that this is significant but not
because of ideological differences
between Paris and Alison that quite
frankly I don't think exists well I
think it's significant because it gives
a message that the Democrats are going
to continue on this centrist
establishment way Republican light you
could call it you could and I mean
really
that Hillary Clinton lost the selection
to the most unpopular presidential
candidate of all time and that in the
past DNC chair w Wasserman Schultz was
playing favorites doctors ill with they
playing favorites I mean you could argue
that they should just give it to the
Bernie progressive wing of the party as
if it's their turn now that I think is
the real reason why keith ellison
announced he was running i think it was
like november 15th very shortly after
the election about a month later Tom
Kara's announced that he was running we
know that he was sort of recruited to
run by the Obama administration there
are 18 different emails in the John
Podesta WikiLeaks emails between Podesta
and Paris would show that they were very
very tight in and what I think this is
really about is it's not about the
politics of Allison and Perez it's about
ensuring or attempting to prevent the
Bernie wing of the Democratic Party from
having influence and that I think is
what you're getting at Pat that is
absolutely spot-on here and we are going
to need to really think about whether
this is a party that by making this
decision has committed to losing I don't
know for how long I hope that's not the
case because the Republican Party under
Trump has become more unhinged than in a
very very long time but I do not believe
that this is the right decision just
doesn't mean that I support or defend
everything that keith Ellison had said
done and stood for we could analyze that
piece by piece but it is more about the
idea of Tom Perez over keith Ellison and
the aspects of the Democratic Party that
they represent today's program sponsored
in part by blue apron where for under
ten bucks per person per meal blue apron
delivers easy to follow recipes along
with pre-portioned ingredients courtesy
of 150 local farms ranches and fisheries
across the united states right to your
door and i probably a broken record at
this point about this i hate throwing
food away and blue apron shih tzu the
exact amount of each ingredient that's
required for a recipe so you end up with
zero food waste and it includes
everything you need to make home cooked
delicious sustainable meals in 40
minutes or less some of
Emile's available in February include
Sudan noodle soup with miso and soft
boiled eggs I'm a big miso guy at this
point I've become hugely into me so
crispy barramundi with quinoa and
roasted carrot salad also on the
februari menu with blue apron cashew
chicken stir-fry with tango mandarins
and jasmine rice you can check out this
week's menu get your first 3 meals for
free of course with free shipping by
going to blue apron calm / Pakman you'll
love it you'll love how good it feels
and tastes to create great home-cooked
meals go to blue apron calm taqman three
meals free plus free shipping